please be with you thank you for tuning
into the D show another exciting episode
thank you for joining us here on the D
show we're gonna talk about back home
food culture and some of the
backwardness that's crept into the
mustards and we're trying to help
educate those who are tomorrow's leaders
who are trying to help to build a better
society because Islam has all the
answers and it's been sent to us as a
mercy for all of mankind so we're gonna
help everyone try to understand some of
these back home cultures and if you're a
young student growing up and in the
United States and your parents do that's
all they want you to be as a doctor
engineer and now maybe you want to be a
share maybe you want to be an imam
you're gonna be a spiritual doctor but
now you're feeling the fuel of the fire
from your family because they're
undermining this field these are the
kind of things we're gonna be talking
about on this week's show so don't go
anywhere
we're here with our special guests in
maschmann dean on the day show we'll be
right back
this is the please be with you and bless
you there's a greeting of Jesus isn't it
it is don't we love Jesus
wait don't and now that Muslims know
this obviously but we we get a lot of
wear on we're on several satellite
channels thank God all over the globe
and many we get a lot of emails from the
not-yet Muslims people who've watched
the Deen show and they really love the
positive message the message of purpose
the purpose of life so we let them into
our lives and we talk about different
issues real important issues and one of
those issues we're gonna be talking
about today is the back home culture -
back home mentality
some have some experience with this well
naturally as an imam yes we whoa what do
we mean when we say okay this is back
home but in Midtown because we know
Islam the way that Jesus live you know
some people are surprised when they hear
this you know but we know it's not means
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation so Islam has been there
since the beginning and it came with all
the prophets so we know Islam is not
backwards nor can it be backwards but
Muslims can be backwards is that right
yes let's talk about this oh yes there's
a difference between what Islam itself
is and that is a way of life guidance
and how to live the best life possible
so that this experience can be as
meaningful and as fulfilling and as
happy as can you manely be possible and
achievable before having ultimately the
greatest of what God Almighty what Allah
the one God in Arabic has promised us of
eternal happiness in the life Hereafter
so that's the religion as opposed to the
humans now who basically seek to
understand and to live it in the way
that the Prophet peace be upon him the
Prophet Muhammad that is may a lost
peace and blessings be upon him and upon
all the prophets how he came to
demonstrate it to show it
we don't we have a we have an epidemic
now I've become a real big problem I
mean it's it's good in a way definitely
that you're you know parents are
encouraging their kids to be the the
best you know in whatever field that
they choose to want to undergo but we
were talking about that there's kind of
been set feels that if you're not you're
pretty much a failure if you're not a
doctor or an engineer you know in in in
this certain community can you go ahead
and lab right on this well it seems that
when we're talking about culture in the
way that we're a product of our
environment certain communities from
overseas they have a priority of what's
the most successful that a person can be
in life and so they'll view for example
medicine to be a doctor as the top and
second to that will be for example
engineering and third will be that which
deals with you know computer technology
in the field of computers and so on so
they have like this hierarchy and
however it may be in whatever area they
come from it may be because of the
amount of money that it can generate it
may be because of the amount of
Education that's involved or the the
difficulty of getting into these you
know universities to study that
particular field but the end result is
that there is a hierarchy of what is the
most prestigious career that a person
can have and then it works its way down
mhm and then from there you I mean we
hear like in many of the youth complain
like if I don't become an a doctor or an
engineer and then from there I'm
basically a fader in my parents eyes and
I mean obviously Islam show that you
need to respect your parents you know
you really there's practically no old
folks home and Islam is there well not
yet yeah there's really a high regard
for parents but how can we hold the
balance here medium where obviously
you're respectful for your parents but
let's say the young child really wants
to to go ahead and be a spiritual doctor
right he wants to be someone who's out
there helping to you know be an imam
maybe or share or or you know this is
really his calling but now the the
parents they put disposition as
something that's you know
something that it's it's one of the
knockoff positions like if you can't be
you know a doctor engineer or maybe in
computer science feel okay go ahead you
can be any mom and really undermining
this position is a bad thing well look
you know it would seem that part of the
reasoning why they would have doctor
engineer etc is because they're looking
at the amount of money that these
positions generate and it's very sad and
it's unfortunate if there's a belief
that says well if my son can't be a
doctor can't be an engineer can't be a
computer specialist then last but not
least the kind of save the honor of the
family to save the face as they would
say sometimes that they would then send
them off to a madrasah or to become you
know someone who memorizes for honors
ashay or something of that sort that
type of a mentality is a sinful one
because that's such a belittling of what
is an Islamic Lee not just symbolic but
is an actually essential aspect of our
religion to belittle it to that point
where it's as if well if you can't
become the greatest of this dis this
then you know at least if you're gonna
be a loser let it be in this form of
being somebody who still has some sense
of value that type of a mentality that
type of a belief is something that's
actually disgraceful it's something that
Islamic Lee is unacceptable I mean
obviously there's there's other fields
also you know if someone wants to be a
journalist someone wants to you can name
some other fields I mean this is
obviously acceptable in the Dean isn't
it absolutely it's it's something that's
understood that we need to have every
type of a career every type of a
profession every type of a technic
technical skill that's out there from
mechanics that teachers to the Baker's
so you name it we need them all and so
if everybody were to be a doctor in the
same way that if everybody were to be a
chef life would be incomplete and so
it's not about the you know minimizing
these other fields rather it's about
seeing that we complete each other it's
very important so when we talk about we
talk about back home man touted you I
mean we know that obviously like I said
earlier Islam is not backward Islam
progresses with with the time but
there's certain principles that we
compromise can you elaborate on some of
this give us an example well yes when it
comes to the principles that are
established that there's you know
they're gonna be there and they're gonna
hold the truth of regardless of the
times that there's only one God you know
Arabic Allah and Allah has the creator
and the creator is the one who has made
all that exists and he is also the
maintainer and the provider for all that
he created and he out of this we should
recognize the greatness of Allah through
seeing his creation and that should help
us to further one to demonstrate our
love to Allah this is something that's
stable that there's no change with
regards to it however there's things
that are you know there's room for
expression and it's it's some of these
cultural things so in this time for
example you don't have to only eat rice
you can eat pasta you can eat bread you
can have different types of things so
long as the restrictions are met and
that is to not have that which is of
pork to not have alcohol and some of the
other finer things want take a break and
we'll be right back with more
backwardness and it creeping up into
even the mustards so we got a exciting
program with the Imams from a team here
in the D show don't go anywhere
why not
everybody's got expensive - hey what's
wrong hey what's going on back there
he's not breathing hello Berber oh my
god Cory unison yeah if I told my aunt
when I'm at ofa una hora con yahoo
meltia
fellas your honeymoon
nerdy what wouldn't fill a janitor Circo
de sus 1l higher to dunya
in a matter
you
back here on the D show and we're
talking about backwardness and Islam's
not backwards Islam actually goes with
the times because we have a thing called
thick right so that's the deriving the
jurisprudence on certain things that
have developed now that we didn't have
let's say way back then and we say that
Islam when it was implemented for
instance during the time of Spain it was
at the you know this is a golden ages
right people in the darkness and Islam
you know in science and we have there's
a book out there a thousand and one
inventions this is by the Muslims isn't
it correct yeah but now a lot of times
with religion you know people they go
ahead and attribute backwardness and but
there is some backwardness into Muslims
we said in a specific situation we hear
this a lot a lot of the people of now
that scholars who they are the spiritual
doctors right this is even more
important than a doctor who sang lives
the spiritual doctors one who saved in
the hearts and souls correct okay
definitely of tremendous importance but
now it's undermined right so now let's
say a person wants to let's give it a
specific situation someone who's any mom
like yourself for instance or someone
else who's leading a community but now
you have because you have in Islam you
have Shura right
what can you equate this to a board the
board people as a Shura because now you
have board members who come in have
little knowledge of Islam or they have a
lot of knowledge in in in medicine but
now they undermine the position of the
scholar the Imam and everything is just
going backwards have you have any
experience with this or known anybody
who's dealing with stuff like this
well you know when we talk about the
word surah it's it's to be understood
that it's talking about consultation
consultation and we recognize when we
look at things from a worldly
perspective that when a person is
seeking consultation it's specific to a
particular you know field right so for
example of a person is going to have a
medical issue they're going to seek
second opinions maybe even third
ian's right and it's understood it's
natural but they're seeking it from home
once again the people that are
specialists in that field
sometimes the physicians themselves will
do this the problem that we have
sometimes is that within our Islamic
organizations or our Mossad yet when we
don't take these best principles these
best practices these standards which are
really Islamic ones and we we through
doing that we do it this service so we
are showing as if Islam is backwards
because we ourselves may be in not
applying what Islamic Lee really is a
best practice and standard that is used
even in in non-religious fields and
non-religious organizations that really
are the foundation for specialization
what happens if you get a whole bunch of
people who may not have anything of a
relationship to a particular subject and
you seek opinions from all of them you
have what's called pooled ignorance and
sometimes this is what happens religion
is not a free-for-all no field is
free-for-all we recognize the need for
specialization in every field has its
its its foundation of whether it's
mathematics or science or literature or
history whatever it may be and we
recognize that and we have our
limitations the same thing is true even
in Islam and this is something that the
Prophet Valley salatu salam taught us
and he showed us he demonstrated for us
so let's give some specific examples
because we'll see that someone will be a
leader in the community and obviously
that position is such a valuable
position but let's say you have certain
board members and we see this prevalent
in a lot of the massage in a lot of the
mosques where now there's a conflict
between the person who should be leaving
the ameer the imam would be the mir
right the person who's should be
listened to and obviously if he's if
he's or he's doing things in the best
interest of the community
adhering to the Koran Anderson is this
correct well that's what the prophetic
model was it for us as Muslims we need
to be convinced that what the Prophet at
least allowed to said I'm a lost peace
and blessing be upon him what he himself
lived what he demonstrated and what he
died upon that's what's best for us so
in his time he was the Amir he was the
Imam he was all of these things and he
was not a you know a viewed upon in
anything less except as being the
Messenger of Allah and being the the
example the role model for them when it
comes to our Messiah the same thing
should be true that the Imam is not
viewed as an employee that he is not
looked upon as a person who was to be
told what to do to be led but rather he
is there to lead and there's a big
difference between it when everybody
should be able to acknowledge that so
the Imam as you'll hear in many of these
communities will they say he is our
leader he is our this well if he's the
leader then he really needs to be
empowered so that he can truly lead and
if being empowered it means that he
needs to then follow what the prophetic
example was the prophet alayhi salaatu
said i'm he had people working with him
as a team he knew who his congregation
who is Demara was and this is why he
would select the people that were that
really stood out in whatever their
strengths were and that's what he
empowered them with and he delegated to
them of tasks and he set them free to
take it to whatever boundary they could
reach with it in the way that we do
things that our Messiah did we have like
these weird concoctions of all sorts of
different things we have some Islamic
elements and we have other very
unassuming elements which we try to make
Islamic we have boards that come in and
out every two years where there is
tremendous instability three four or
five years doesn't make a difference or
we have it and so when they're switched
you have now this instability that's
caused but the main person who's there
who's there in day and out with regards
to whoever's of leadership or in these
positions and yet unfortunately they're
given the most miniscule of positions of
roles of authority of even being able to
lead the other extreme is where you have
these shorter councils as their call
where it's really a death tell you know
you know till they die basically till
death do us part we're in the same way
that when we look at our organ in our
countries back home where you have these
leaders that for you know 40 50 60 years
they have sat in these positions and
according to them everything is the best
that it could possibly be but you go
ahead and look at the effects of their
leadership and their their organizations
and administration's and how that's
really impacting the people it's a
failure they don't want to at the same
time recognize that hey look it's gotta
be the Islamic example the role model
how he himself the Prophet is allowed to
Sam taught lived and died doing things
or it's not at all really Islamic we're
gonna gonna take a break when we right
back with more to wrap this session up
on a Deen show with him Osmond Dean
don't go anywhere we're right back she
had often mistranslated as holy war the
word jihad means to struggle Islam does
not preach violence it does not preach
vicious holy war it certainly does not
condone terror and suicide bombing Islam
preaches compassion tolerance and
justice find the truth about Islam call
toll-free 877 why Islam order your FREE
copy of the Quran today
I am Not Afraid to stand alone if a box
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side I am Not Afraid
back here on the Dean show so how can
the Imam the spiritual leader in the
Masjid who's supposed to be the Emir how
can because you have a lot of people who
want to do some good so they might you
know really have some good intentions
and they want to do good for the
community but now they end up getting in
the way they cause more they don't show
the proper respect towards the person
who's supposed to be an authority and
they end up causing more harm than good
so what advice would you give for
someone who possibly wants to be on the
board of a mus JIT who is on a board you
have a lot of experience there what
would you give advice so there can be
there's good collaboration so we can
really move forward as a community and
not backwards yeah basically you said is
is is what needs to be done firstly to
have a good intention at hamdulillah
that's fantastic we praise and thank
Allah if a person has that but
understand that that's something that
only Allah knows because what's in my
heart
whether that's what's being expressed or
not Allah only knows that but it's not
enough and this is where we need to
understand that if we're going to truly
take the Masjid and have it fulfilled
the different roles and functions that
are so essential for the Muslim
community men women young old recent
converts as well as the non-muslims that
are also they have expectations from us
it requires more than good intentions it
requires that whoever is going to be
involved that they understand that they
need to have some skills they need to
have some abilities and so this is where
truly if you want to talk about Shura
they need to consult with the Imam this
is where the Imam is a person that
should be trusted this is where the
community who has hired the person that
they need to have trust and faith in
them and they need to work with them he
is a person who is now going to be able
to look at whatever skills people have
for example there's some of our younger
brothers and sisters who are excellent
when it comes to technology where you
can give them these opportunities to
develop the website to go ahead and use
the media in a way that's going to
communicate connect with the youth
there's other people who must shout love
for example they may be great at
generating revenue making money it would
be a shame to take a person like that
and put them in the kitchen for example
and having them bake or whatever the
case is
and this is where we find that the
Prophet Alisa led to some really
excelled he saw the likes of for example
oh baby no cabin of the law and ho Allah
be pleased with him that he was an
expert when they came to reciting the
Quran he praised them so whoever wants
to learn how to recite the Quran fresh
just like it was revealed they should
learn it from a baby no cab and that's
what he set him up for so when people
now today want to go ahead and they want
to volunteer they want to be a part of
something that's great but it shouldn't
be half hazard it should be organized it
should be in a way that things function
in a way that is going to be best and
this is what you know this whole best
practices quality control all sorts of
different industries have their own
measures best standards and practices in
streamlining things are so essential and
when you have a stable figure like the
Imam in the community people need to
work with them they need to realize hey
I have intention that is to serve a lot
to do good I have energy I may have
whatever skills and abilities how can
you best see me using it and then to
work as a team have you seen this we've
heard some some some stories where you
have someone who is he's graduated you
know from a prestigious Islamic
University he's come back to help lead
his community but now you have also
someone who's also become a doctor in a
certain field he becomes a board
president and now he you know puts you
know his degree above the Islamic
scholars degree and now he starts
basically not only can he dictate him
medicine but he tries to dictate to him
you know the thick of this to figure
that basically he undermines his
position and now there's a class we have
you seen a lot of this happening also
well that definitely happens yeah and
unfortunately that's a very grave mossad
because when it comes to anybody's
specific field we understand that
there's a tremendous amount of respect
for specialization that's one of the
things that has helped America to really
reach its climax specialization you have
people that are experts in their field
you empower them you
helped to further provide for them
resources whatever they case is so that
they can reach what they may not even
know of their own potential in and take
things to new levels this is what should
be taking place within our message it
also and hamdulillah people who have
become medical doctors engineers
whatever it is that's great but there
should be a tremendous amount of respect
for Islamic scholarship too just because
the person may have a degree in whatever
field it is it doesn't mean that they
now know whatever it is that they need
to know about Islam a person may have
read the Quran from cover to cover ten
times a hundred times it does not mean
that they're an expert in what the Quran
teaches and in Islam and so when it
comes to these these different
individuals they need to humble
themselves they should not see
themselves as being the you know the
board or the bosses or you know the
directors and they're delegating to the
Imam do this don't do this rather they
should see themselves at the service of
what Islam is about working together
with the Imam under his leadership
because we're talking about an Islamic
organization we're not talking about a
hospital we're not talking about a
clinic we're not talking about the
engineering firm we're not talking about
anything else except what a place that
is meant to fulfill what la ilaha
illallah muhammadur rasulu laws about
that there is no God in truth except for
Allah was one and then he alone deserves
to be worshipped and that should be done
according to the Sunnah of the messenger
mohammed salameh ISM so we talked about
having the proper intention if you're
gonna get involved in any activities
that you want to obviously donate your
time but also knowledge how important is
really having the right knowledge
because yeah you could be an engineer or
a doctor but now you know you you have
to have some good basic knowledge at
least of this Deen you know isn't this
really important before you do the
action now yes and this is why we find
that in Islam in order for anything of
our actions or our deeds to be accepted
they must fulfill two conditions the
first is that it must be done sincerely
for Allah so alhamdulillah the Muslims
who have that that's fantastic and
allows the one who judges we don't judge
in the second is that it needs to be
done according to the Sunnah of the
Prophet and it's out to CERN so that if
it's not then it takes it away from what
he himself taught and what he has
established and most of the time that
would be considered a bead on just like
in the first case if it's not done
sincerely for Allah that would be
considered [ __ ] that is being
than for other than Allah whether it's
to show off or who knows what the second
would be an innovation in the religion
and so both of these need to be there
the intention itself is not enough
following what the Prophet himself
established of best practices over 1400
years ago it's absolutely essential so
what what other advice do you have for
for people who are in the community on
some of the boards may be out there and
there you know try to make a difference
and maybe they might because a lot of
the moistures they have these conflicts
from within what advice would you would
you have before we wrap up for these
individuals well let's understand that
it's a it's an act of worship that these
different positions if a person is truly
trying to do something for the religion
it's an act of worship so it needs to be
taken seriously secondly it means that
because it's an act of worship they need
to do things with knowledge and this is
where the Imam is indispensable so they
need to have the Imam really be an
integral part of anything that's taking
place in the organization
they need to be on constant
communication they need to be working
together as a team everybody needs to be
humble recognizing that yeah there's
going to be mistakes but we learn from
mistakes we'd better ourselves from the
mistakes that we may make where they
need to realize that they all have a
common goal and purpose and if they were
to do this following what is truly the
best practices of what the Prophet
himself established I think that our
message would truly be the magnets and
the beehives that are bustling with
activity with energy with with results
in a way that they're lacking now or in
a way that we may feel we have to some
extent but to a totally different degree
that would really make us look back in
comparison and say wow where we were at
and we thought we were great as opposed
to where greatness really is an
excellence that's all the time we have
so if somebody now also is because we
hear a lot about this and if you have
someone else who's going through these
situations and they want some
consultation on the matter how do they
get a hold of you is that possible
sure I think the best way is through my
email which is I'll spell it out and so
it's my first name plus my last initial
so SHP
en di M n at gmail.com so spending and
all one word at gmail.com so like
they're seeing your name spendin misako
at gmail.com right except that it's not
my full last name just the initial of my
last name is just the initial okay thank
you very much you're the crater that
happens at work Allah rewards you I mean
thank you and thank you again for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
so just some advice for myself and
everybody knowing how important
knowledge is because if you've become a
doctor you know how much time or an
engineer how much time you spent reading
taking classes to get to the position
where you're at
we should never undermine this knowledge
in this Deen this Deen this way of life
of all the messengers of God Islam
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation and really putting in
time the same amount if not that at
least a fraction of the amount of time
to really know this Deen according to
the verbatim would have God the Koran
and the way of life the cinema that we
have preserved of the last and final
messenger problem Hamid peace be upon
him so really taking the time to study
it to learn it and we need teachers
because imagine learning boxing
jiu-jitsu or your profession as a doctor
and not having good qualified teachers
and we respected those teachers didn't
we so we should really respect the
scholars the people that are out there
are the spiritual physicians and as long
as they're pointing us in the direction
because the scholars are the inheritors
of the prophets so as long as they're
encouraging us according to the Quran
and Sunnah we should really respect them
and sit at their feet and learn this way
of life because that's how by studying
Islam you are more convinced of it
because it's not blind faith the more
you study the verbatim word of the crowd
the more you're convinced of it the more
it makes sense and the more your iman
increases connect with us all the time
on Facebook like us there follow us on
Twitter tune in to the Deen show every
week for a new show we'll see you next
time God willing until that peace be
with you